this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
manscape is the premier brand for men's
grooming products and accessories
they have everything you need to level
up your
full body grooming needs we have the
perfect package 3.0 kit
by manscape right here check it out
testicles
this is the world's first all-in-one
manscaping kit your bowls will thank you
it comes with the lawnmower 3.0 body
trimmer it's waterproof and it has
advanced skin saving technology so you
don't cut yourself
when i need to look for my phone i have
this flashlight
find it you know yeah it also comes with
ball deodorant and ball
toner to keep your balls from smelling
yucky
because it keeps it smelling fresh ball
toners are good balls
oh man that's a real man smell for a
limited time
the perfect package includes two free
gifts the shed travel bag in the
manscape
anti-shaking boxer ball reefs
look at that baby the boxer briefs might
be one of our favorite parts of the
collection because so soft
and it's made of this micro fiber blend
so when you get a boner
and then it goes up it doesn't feel
so rough it might might give you a
buttercress little soft and it feels
good dude my hands getting a boner like
because it feels so soft i touch it
yep oh wow this
very same fabric repels moisture and it
helps your balls
breathe this is moisture it's like
and it's brother balls are breathing it
also has
optimal temperature control with their
crop
cooling technology so if your balls have
a fever
so whether you're lounging around the
house or working out these boxers
they're gonna keep you cool and dry all
day long
if you go to massgame.com right now you
can get 20
off wow plus free international shipping
on everything right here and more dude
that is
fancy we'll have the link in the
description below check it out
[Music]
so when we are trying to find partners
romantically we usually try to find
a companion this way our personality
matches our uh our sense of humor maybe
or things we like we try to find things
that
you know we're similar and we can you
know match up and it's a perfect
fit yeah now there is a new way
of finding the perfect fit opposites
uh not quite uh a doctor
in the uk is specializing in making
designer
vagina oh my god that's dope her
philosophy
is that sometimes the perfect fit is
just
maybe the penis eyes and the vagina size
need to be the better fit and if you
have a better love life
a better sex life your romance your
relationship
can flourish in a better uh better way
designer
designer vagina they're telling me
there's about to be gucci coochies dog
like gucci gucci
[Laughter]
if they break gucci oh sure that's a
different size
it's got to cut design you gotta get a
redesign oh wait there's like an
operation happening
for me this is a plastic surgery oh yeah
this is this is a surgery yes yeah uh
what they do
uh i'm changing my [ __ ] vagina sorry
dude to help you understand
you don't want it to be designer [ __ ] no
not that peasant [ __ ] feel like you're
already
a key fits the luck
[Music]
if it didn't i wouldn't be changing it
the lock can always get better
the lock can always advance upgrade the
locks with the key i got the key yeah
he might be crooked or rusty or broken
worn out yeah you got to reshape the key
place the keys sharp the way it was you
might have to duplicate the key
oh yeah try different keys you know i'll
duplicate it
or maybe just differently or sometimes
you just gotta try different locks then
too yeah yeah yeah
when you change the lock you gotta
change the key yes new surgery there it
is
yes i mean as long as it's fair i'm cool
with it hashtag
i'm gonna make merch that says gucci
cookies yeah man you're getting all
sorts of ideas
my there we go
here we go we're we're figuring out your
only fan's branding here
i like it i better see that let's go all
right so to help you understand
what a designer vagina is sounds nice
gucci gucci
they will undergo a combination of
non-surgical vaginal tightening
and surgical labiaplasty which is
basically like think lip reduction
fillers but in your vagina yeah but the
lip has
nothing to do with helping me
i mean i think they're also redesigning
the weight
what do you need what do you know i mean
what do you mean
it feels good when you're hitting
against it
but it doesn't make a huge difference in
the tightness but visually it's like
damn
oh that's true it's visually that's true
wait so so feeling wise though
it's the same sometimes it's ugly as
[ __ ] but it feels amazing yeah
but then it doesn't look appetizing it's
like food
some a lot of asian food you know it
looks like vomit true and then you just
like i'm not sure man and then you take
a bite and you're just like it's pretty
good
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's so delicious is
the vagina ever
uh a good looking thing to you guys oh
hell yeah
i appreciate the way the vagina looks
yeah there's a dude
i could [ __ ] sit and stare at a
vagina like this for like 30 minutes and
be like
that's a that's a nice damn that's a
nice that is a gucci coochie
yeah that's a [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
yeah but there's some where i'm just
like i'd rather not
look at it today i turn the lights off i
just
how can such a beautiful girl have such
a weird looking [ __ ]
wow like is this an allergic reaction or
whatever yeah like
why yeah but
i mean it's just it's not uh like it
doesn't feel for different what do you
say different feel for different kills
man
how do you know what that means you know
what it means i know what it means
exactly some some [ __ ] look lactose
intolerant
ugly vagina than a penis and balls
really
so ugly to me to you they're just so
gross that is nasty to me have you ever
seen penis and balls like that one's not
that bad
there's some good looking penis and
balls oh
you're more yeah i think you don't like
i don't know i think i'm i'm more about
like if it fits then great
and i think we're great so we don't need
surgery no i mean not for me
do you think i need surgery i don't
think you need surgery don't go there
casey
what other asset could he possibly get
the lock and key are perfect in this
situation
no other answer there's no other answer
then you pass that
what if casey is like your [ __ ] doesn't
need surgery but your butthole does
well if you want your mouth because he
never gets to go back
oh what if what if before this even
talking about this like you're just
chilling on the couch and he sends you
this link
and it's just like honestly no if it was
like a legit
yeah if it was like a legit concern and
he was like you know what i feel like we
could just have a lot more fun if we
were a better fit
then i'd be like cool let's look into
penis like gucci penis or whatever there
are no
that doesn't work we gotta come over we
gotta come over here we gotta come over
if you can find one then i think it's
worth changing the penis but gucci
coochies too gucci gucci's
pretty elite you gotta keep wait we've
heard about men growing dicks
we've heard about men growing dicks off
their marketing and they added two extra
eggs
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh pieces of their
arm and
yeah yeah they'll grow the dick on their
actual yeah got two forearms just
exactly on one arm oh [ __ ] yeah it's
already happening no but the marketing
isn't as good
right from the arm yeah
it's like wolverine but it's like dick
vereen
the first thing that they said because
casey was in here yesterday when we did
this
the first thing that bart said was like
he could be like super spider-man he'd
be like jerk himself
that's pretty good that's good but yeah
so uh for for men's penises uh there's
also
uh a possible surgery if the vagina is
good but the penis needs to fit the
vagina better
see uh you can increase the men's penis
girth with filler
send me that or even send me that link
i'll send it to you yeah so yeah so they
can even grab
fat from your own body and then and put
it into your dick
so then that way your dick is actually
girthier good way
now we're talking there we go that's all
i wanted to know
is is there a guy's version it
definitely goes both ways
i i was never opposed to the to the idea
of guys having it i'm just still
fine i just don't know how to beat gucci
gucci like we need
something you guys will come up with it
you guys
like throw out designer brands quick
rolex armani
rolex [ __ ] flex nah hot flex oh you guys
are trying to name your the penis
[Music]
we already said all of them boss but it
doesn't yeah
supreme [ __ ] no no no no no no no no
don't worry
no not good no but
no no that sounded better in my mind
yeah
valencia
designer anus now is that what it would
be designer this is i don't know
it's that's tough that's that's i don't
think you could top that to be honest
that might be we peaked already i think
so maybe we gotta get away from clothing
and luxury where it has to go into cars
cars lamborghini and now
i don't like that i like that
lamborghini
i'm gonna get a lamborghini a now just a
brown car
what's a lamborghini
i say supposed to be yeah i've heard
that many times it was a joke i always
thought it was like
me too who says portia my mom
my mom the older generation my mom
always called it a porsche and i was
like you're so stupid and i'm like oh
actually i think she was right
how did germans pronounce porsche is it
porsha is it german
i thought it was british i think i'm
pretty sure it was like
european it's german european german
yeah germany is in europe well
i have a question that goes back to the
article how much are they charging
that i do not have information let me
look up it better be expensive that's
just luxury
let me look up this doctor dr lucy
glancy yeah i wouldn't feel confident
she'd be fixing up them glance she's not
very
fancy fancy glancing
damn all the branding just works for
women it doesn't [ __ ] work for men
dude
guys loves boring i know
designer [ __ ] sounds better than
designer dick though yeah
i think guys got to be more practical
like [ __ ] depot
oh i like that dick depot yeah it's got
to be like just
cockmark just the way it is yeah like
cockmark beautiful
that works oh yeah yeah we need to we
need to devaluate them yeah
yeah we gotta we gotta shut the bar
lower for the dudes for sure
wonder the high class stuff doesn't work
it's gotta be maybe that's why they say
like
like us guys put [ __ ] on pedestals
like yeah because
it's luxurious you know the truth you
know what it is yeah you know what it is
guys belong the subway i think down
there so if you want to have
a designer vagina or gucci poochie
gucci gucci gucci poochie is a yeah it's
a good stuff that's kind of yeah
yeah uh prices start at 2 500
pounds that's like six thousand dollars
is that six thousand dollars nah
it's not that much but yeah two thousand
five
it sounds like a deal kind of i think it
doubles does it double i don't know
i think it's actually pretty close yeah
i don't know if the dollar is weaker
i hope it doesn't ruin our key goals
though well isn't that a muscle
it's just the muscle that you're
contracting actually make the kegels
better because you're you're also
you've never done a kick i don't know
how to keep going yeah you do
your pelvic floor muscles yeah yeah like
i'm doing it right now it's like you a
guy oh when you squeeze your butt hole
maybe when it's like in the middle of
your butthole yeah yeah i don't know
that was the same thing as the lady
that's the pelvic floor i feel like it's
the same i mean
it's not the same but it's like the same
like you're tightening yeah yeah i like
how we're all doing maybe that's nice
it's harder yeah maybe that's how you
grow what you're doing
i'm flicking my dick and squeezing my
butthole i'm squeezing my taint
i was watching this tantrum can you like
tighten your balls no no no
they go up like an elevator by itself oh
yeah yeah when it's cold they're
up there when it's cold when it's hot no
i knew that for sure it's like an animal
you were able to still move it kind of
like with the dick
no no no no well it does you do your
butthole
like tense up like the balls do kind of
go up a little bit
or when you cough doesn't move yeah when
you cough it goes phone
boom
[Laughter]
that's a little earthquake holy [ __ ]
you know how guys can move or even girls
like the pectoral muscles
i thought you could do that with your
balls oh no that'd be cool though
but then the way it moves naturally it's
like you ever go to a tide pool and you
touch a [ __ ] see an enemy and it goes
like that
that's how [ __ ] balls moves wow that
was like that was very good
that's a good performance yup it's like
an animal of its own a milly rock just
[Music]
you